et nous sommes avec un est-il député de
l'oise bonsoir bonsoir ci d'avoir
accepté notre invité sur le préfet de
l'oise on a appris tout à l'heure a été
confiné cet après midi il avait été en
contact direct avec le maire de crépy en
valois tester lui positif coronavirus le
sous préfet de senlis a lui aussi été
confinés est ce que ce sont selon vous
des mesures nécessaires qui s'imposent
et je n'ai pas connaissance que nous
avons aussi directeur de la rs alors
dans l'oise dans l'oise c'est très clair
les les les consignes sont sont
radicales on ne peut pas aller des
écoles sont fermées dans plusieurs
villages pour vous les nommez à
l'aéroport on sait par les terminaux on
peut faire un cas ouvrir interminables
sur deux et on ne peut pas aller au
cinéma
tous les rassemblements comme vous dites
marchés brocantes loto soirée les
meetings électoraux
tout ce qui peut être rassemblement
effectivement interdit
on demande de limiter les déplacements
au strict nécessaire évidemment vous
pouvez aller faire vos courses mais mais
si vous pouvez faire le télétravail chez
vous c'est mieux voilà on demande
on demande toutes ces précautions parce
que tout de même nous sommes un foyer
qui tu veux pas dire que c'est parti de
là mais en tout cas nous sommes un foyer
très très très près par par ce virus
c'est l'un des foyers de l'épidémie en
france vous êtes dont député de ce
département de l'oise
comment très concrètement s'organise la
gestion de cette crise dans le
département mais aussi entre le
gouvernement et le département que quels
sont les liens qui s'opère au quotidien
j'imagine tout au long de la journée
un râleur oui donc donc vraiment
monsieur le préfet guy lefrand nous
tient au courant quotidiennement mais
presque heure par heure enfin parce que
ça a évolué très rapidement nous étions
les parlementaires samedi en réunion
avec le directeur de la rs voyez ça ça
évolue quotidiennement
le dernier bilan faisait état de 50
contamination dans l'oise sont jour ses
chiffres il a augmenté à l'heure qu'il
est ce sont ceux que j'aime et voyez
c'était 28 samedi soir donc ça évolue
très vite vos voilà on est vraiment on
est vraiment tenu au courant par par la
r
parle parle le monsieur le préfet tout
est vraiment fait pour que nous soyons
bien informée je tiens aussi quand même
un rassurer enfin je ne sais pas si
c'est tellement le propos mais mais je
pense que certes il faut être très
prudent et prendre les mesures les
mesures qui à faire si les écoles sont
fermées c'est très rare c'est
exceptionnel donc il doit il ya des
raisons évidemment exceptionnels mais en
même temps je pense que très
concrètement que le virus le plus
dangereux c'est la peur et la panique et
celle ci elle empoisonne tous les
rapports humains est notre bien le plus
précieux qui est notre humanité le lien
social
il faut être très clair sur 100 sur 100
individus qui seraient contaminés 80
guérisse naturellement il faut le dire
sans être obligé de passer par une
hospitalité elles seront linguère ils
sont naturellement comme vous verrez
c'est chez vous de la grippe et d'un
rhume que sais-je
le 80 guérissent naturellement alors
qu'elles sont qu'un seul des contaminés
pour qui l'état clinique et un peu plus
calanques et bisous alors voilà donc ce
80 guérissent naturellement 15 ont des
problèmes et sont hospitalisés et soigné
cinq courts un vrai risque dont trois
qui beurre 3 sur 100 n'est ce pas
donc le profil pour l'instant on n'a pas
dont on n'a pas d'enfant et pas du jeune
dans l'oise
évidemment bien que j'allais dire comme
la grippe comme ce qui serait un peu
vulnérable une personne âgée une
personne corps a été opéré des poumons
mais il peut toujours y avoir des
exceptions
si vous êtes dans un un cas où vous
étiez je ne sais pas déprimer fragile
bref en tout cas je pense qu'il faut
dire comment ça s'attrape 1 n'est ce pas
il faut éviter prendre toutes les
précautions se laver les mains plusieurs
fois par heure évitez sépare le
postillon les postillons lorsqu'on parle
si on éternue évidemment il faut se
protéger il faut pas éternuer comme ça
faut tousser dans son coude mais
j'allais dire on ne peut pas s'empêcher
de vivre sinon sinon c'est le pire virus
et contient un virus invisible comme ça
note celui en face de nous devient
presque notre ennemi alors les
établissements scolaires vous l'avez
indiqué les établissements scolaires de
9 communes ennuis de l'oise sont fermés
depuis ce matin et ce jusqu'au 14 mars
inclus jusqu'à nouvel ordre voilà très
concrètement comment est-ce qu'on va
s'organiser le quotidien des élèves et
puis des parents aussi les parents
vont-ils aussi être amené à rester chez
eux auprès de leurs enfants à leur
charge
j'avais le national avait dit que les
parents étaient aurait aurait d un droit
un droit pour rester et des facilités au
niveau de leur travail au niveau des
congés maladie ars pour pouvoir rester
auprès de leur enfant
clairement voilà on a creil montataire
fin à neuf communes que vous connaissez
sûrement tout est suivi de très près le
vraiment le préfet et l'état suivent de
très près l'évolution dans l'oise
je pense qu'il faut effectivement
prendre toutes ces mesures d'urgence ne
pas j'avais très à continuer à vivre
normalement avec toutes les précautions
évidemment pas se mettre exprès à se
mettre en danger
mais c'est un peu je me pose une
question plus fondamentale
jusqu'où doit-on ôter la liberté de
l'être humain au motif de le protéger
c'est pour moi une vraie question comme
celle de nos aînés qu'on places en ehpad
ça rejoint est ce que est ce qu'on
pourra empêcher de vivre pour empêcher
de mourir face on en est à ce paradoxe
là il faut avant de faire des courses
alors les cours je voyais tout le monde
a touché a touché les produits avant
nous et bien justement quels sont les
remontées du terrain comment réagissent
les habitants de l'oise est ce qu'ils
sont rassurés par ces mesures de
précaution qui sont mises en place est
ce qu'ils sont inquiets
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
entendez eh bien j'ai lentement et
brillance et leurs fans c'est pour ça
que j'essaye d'être un peu rassurante
sur votre antenne si vous me le
permettez parce que je trouve que cette
ambiance-là inquiète tout le monde et il
fallait dire il n'y a pas de raison si
bien sûr il ya une raison il faut être
vigilant
il faut prendre les dispositions sont
prises elles sont prises elles sont
appliquées mais j'ai envie de dire aux
gens mais vivait une vie normale sorte
elysées un bon livre
promenez vous sans vous inquiéter dit
bonjour à votre voisin en tenant les
précautions d'usagé
lavez vous les mains si ici
est malade évidemment ben évitait de de
vous mettre près de lui s'il tous
surtout éloigner vos deux mètres mais ne
nous empêcheront pas 10 parce que là ce
quand on est un virus comme ça invisible
l'être humain le voisin devient un
ennemi et là c'est ennuyeux enfin donc
je vraiment j'ai envie de rassurer tout
le monde
redonnons lessive sur 100 personnes 80
guérissent naturellement 1
la france déploie bond déploie donc la
bonne stratégie pour faire face à la
propagation du virus
on a raison de prendre des précautions
parce que sinon on critiquerait en
disant que rien n'est fait mais il doit
pas s'installer une psychose n'ont plus
lieu
merci beaucoup on a entendu votre
message année style député de l'oise
premier